>>Female speaker: Hi everyone, I'm Heather
Stillman and on behalf of the Authors at Google
team here at Los Angeles, I'm honored to introduce
to you today, my cousin, Karen Krasne, the
owner and executive Chef of Extraordinary
Desserts.
She will be speaking today about her recent
book, Extraordinary Cakes.
Her cakes have graced the cover of Bon Appetite
and Forums recognized her as one of the country's
Ten Best Pastry Chefs.
She has been featured in New York Times, Gourmet,
Sunset and the Los Angeles Times, among other
publications.
In 1988, Karen opened Extraordinary Desserts
in San Diego.
A year later the eatery was in such demand
that Karen was able to expand from ten seats
to sixty-five seats, and in 2004, she opened
a second location in San Diego's Little Italy.
Karen graduated with a degree from the University
of Hawaii in Food and Human Nutrition, and
went on to study pastry making at Le Cordon
Bleu in Paris, France.
She has brought some of these fabulous desserts
to share with us today, and now, Karen Krasne.
>>Karen Krasne: Thank you.
[Audience applauds]
>>Karen: So I'm just going to kinda start
with the concept of what Extraordinary Desserts
is and what it's become.
When we started in 1988, We just did desserts
at our one location that now seats a hundred
and it's desserts seven
days a week.
And then we opened a second location in Little
Italy, where we seat about 250
people, and both locations are open until
about eleven at night, midnight on the weekends.
And at the bigger location
we do have food and wine, paninis and alcohol
and things like that so that we don't just
have the desserts, so we've
become two different places that people love
to go to one or the other, and they're really
fanatical about which one
they prefer.
So it's interesting because some like The
Original, as it's known, and some like The
New.
So I want to go
back a little bit on my background, I know
Heather touched on it.
I am born and raised in San Diego, and I took
off at about seventeen for Hawaii, and somehow
got a degree about eight years later.
And it was Human Nutrition and
it was under the Tropical Ag genre at the
University of Hawaii, so I think that's where
a lot of my tropical
agriculture comes in here, and from there
you pretty much-- this was way way way back
in the old days, so you sort of
had to go and get a Master's in Public Health
or things like that and it just didn't sound
like that was good for me,
so I took off to France, and spent about a
year and half there at different schools,
Cordon Bleu was one of them.
And
then came back to San Diego and started making
cakes for like Nieman Marcus, some other very
high end establishments,
and just sort of dropped off, peddled, you
know basically peddling to them, and built
up a clientele enough that I
could open up a store that had ten seats.
And from there the ten seats grew to sixty-five,
and a hundred and then the
second store, and so on and so forth.
So I don't know, we're in about twenty-two
years of business at this point, and
I decided to write the book, which took maybe
two years to write.
And I felt that it was necessary to document
the
type of work that we do because it is so different
from what you see pretty much anywhere in
the States and then,
likewise in Europe, where I just was for a
couple of weeks and just got back ten days
ago.
So what I think
what we do that's so different is that we
really tried to use a lot of color, and a
lot of fresh whatever is going
on in the market, in terms of flowers and
fruits, and what not, and we also try to do
a spin on flavors so that it's
not just the typical things you'd expect,
chocolate with raspberries, we infuse things,
we use herbs, we use a lot of
yuzu, we use Matcha tea, we tend to follow
the patterns of desserts that are going on
more, say, in the East coast,
because I am in New York quite a bit, and
then in Paris, where I think is where pastry
really has been born, and is
really studied, and has a metamorphosis beyond
anywhere else that I've ever seen.
So I just finished a class over there which
we call stagez.
And it was three days and eighty hours, I
mean three days,
eighty recipes, thirty five hours.
And it was really really incredible what is
happening that is the same as it was
twenty-five years ago, but it's just become
more flavorful, more simplified, less sugar,
less fat.
They're following
the same buzz words we're following here,
but it's introduced in a way that's a little
bit more elegant over there.
Nobody feels that they're skipping or missing
something.
So today I thought that I would make probably
the easiest
recipe in the book.
The recipes tend to take about two or three
days for preparation, because they're cakes,
and then
crèmes and then different layers that you
build on it and then you end up freezing the
product, and then you take it
out the day you're going to serve it and you
finish it up, so that it's nice and hard when
you finish it, so you get
really clean edges like these cakes over here.
If you try to make a cake, and put the frosting
in it and put the next
cake layer on it, and frost it and put another,
and then you try to finish it, I mean it's
all gobbledy-gook and
uneven and you know people always wonder "how
are your cakes so perfect?"
It's because they had a stage where they
got to be frozen for eight hours to twelve
hours to overnight and that's one of the key
things in the book.
But not
everyone has two or three days to make a cake
so there's a few things in the book, one is
the bread pudding.
I'm also
gonna show you, not going to show you how
to make it, but this is an element in the
book, this white chocolate
mousse, instead of having to make the cake
that might take three days, you could just
make the mousse, and I've
simply either put it in a large form in a
glass so you could use any kind of wine glass,
goblet, that kind of thing,
or these are simple votive candles that you
can pick up at Smart and Final.
You can be as creative as you want with
some of the elements of the book and not have
to make cakes with them.
So, I tried to break it down so that it does
seem like you wanna try for some of the hard
projects, but then at the same time, I don't
want to make it so, you
know, full of effort that you don't even want
to open the book.
So, the bread pudding basically has about
5 ingredients in it, and so I take the cream
and the milk, I just put it
together in the pot, and I hope I have heat
going, let's see, it seems like it, okay and
then the sugar is going in
the bowl with the egg yolks, I don't know
if you all use vanilla beans or if you use
vanilla extract.
If you're
using a vanilla bean, you definitely want
it at room temperature, so it's really nice
and pliable.
And then when you
cut it open, you're going to use a sharp little
knife like this to cut it open, and then when
you scrape out the
meat, you use the back of the knife, not the
sharp, because you don't want the pith, which
would be like getting the
pith from an orange or a lemon that's kind
of bitter, so it's real important that your
knife is nice and sharp to cut
open the bean like this and then it's going
to expose this really glistening, sort of
dark meat.
Those are the seeds
and are the most delicious part and the reason
why you pay so much for a vanilla bean.
So, once I have that out, I
just go ahead and put it in the pot in the
cream and the milk, and then I put the whole
bean in there as well.
And
then I've got my yolks and my sugar going
here and I just mix those up, and we're going
to wait for the cream and the
milk to come to almost a boil, and then we'll
pour that into the egg yolk mixture, we'll
strain it, and that's
basically the crème brulee.
So that's an element that you could take as
crème brulee and put in into little porcelain
dishes and bake it off in a water bath in
the oven, and you don't even have to go further
into this other aspect of
it.
One of the things that I do use, that make
it a little bit easier for you, is they're
store bought croissants, and
you need about ten of this size.
And, you know, if they're kind of beige-y,
not real baked off, go ahead and put them
back in your oven and bake them real firm,
because they're going to soak up all this
crème brulee and get nice and
crusty, and it's nice and juicy.
So the flat ones that are not, you know, real
bronzed in color, you definitely want
to bake those again.
And probably put them in at about, I don't
know, three fifty for about ten minutes, and
get them
nice and colored.
And you'll see that they're, you can see inside
of the croissant, you see all the texture
in it.
When they’re real mushy, you know, like
someone flattened 'em out, they're not going
to be as fabulous, so you
definitely want this puffier kind.
Yes?
>>female #1: So how drastic is it between
using real vanilla versus vanilla syrup or
even fake vanilla
extract?
I can guess what you're probably going to
tell me, but...
>>Karen: I know.
So the question is about a vanilla bean, versus
an extract, or fake vanilla or vanilla syrup.
Well,
I mean, your desserts are only as good as
your product.
So I don't know that in this it's a deal breaker
to use a
real vanilla bean but if you're making vanilla
ice cream, if you're making vanilla mousse,
if you're making vanilla
sauce, that would be when I would say you
should probably go buy the vanilla beans.
But in this sort of a situation,
I am using such good chocolate, and this is
valrhona, and I don't know if all of you know
about valrhona chocolate,
but it's from the Rhone region in the Val
area of France, and there's probably, I don't
know, twenty-five different
grades of chocolate, everything from fifty
percent all the way up into eighty-two percent,
and you can pick and
choose your flavors.
We sell ten different styles at Extraordinary
Desserts, I am sure you can find it here at
Surface, but it's excellent chocolate and
the one I am using today is sixty-one percent
and it just has a really true
chocolate flavor, no berries, or jasmine or
coffee notes in it, it's just real clear chocolate.
Okay good, this
is-- thank you.
[laughs]
[tapping on pot]
So, these are going to be our filler, the
chocolate and the croissants, and once this
is finished, we'll put half of
the crème brulee in the bottom, I use this
in the book, this kind of a mold, and you
can either use this kind of a
thing or you can use an oval.
Here's what this one comes up, it's great
for a brunch buffet, this is great family
style.
It's really however you want to present it.
You can also build them in little dishes that
are porcelain like
that.
Same kind of a thing, you just put the crème
brulee in, put the croissants in , then the
chocolate and then
layer them again like that, and then bake
it off and you're right there.
So while we're waiting for this, I don't
know if anyone has any questions about desserts
in general, or have an issue with something
that's not working out,
but I'm not shy so....ask me.
>>female: I have a question, you mentioned
that...first of all thank you so much for
being here.
I
actually came to your store many many times.
Is it working?
Okay.
Many many times in San Diego, um, but my question
was regarding to something you said earlier
about the trend now in Europe is to actually
reduce sugar, reduce fats in
the desserts, and what I saw is like cream
and sugar so this one is definitely not--
[Karen laughs]
Is your store now offering more these things,
I haven't been recently?
>>Karen: Yeah, it's, I mean we're definitely
offering more of vegan, gluten-free kinds
of products because it's a
kind of huge buzz, in all of foods in general,
um, I mean in our downtown location we make
a lot of vegan foods
as well in the salty section of the store,
but there's always vegan cookies available,
and there's always
something that's gluten-free because it has
become such a big thing.
I'm not one that will just make something
vegan
or gluten-free just to be in the market, I
want it to be as good as the other product.
And so then I might choose
either/or, and so it's taken me a little bit
longer to come up with those products that
I think are just as high
quality in flavor and texture, sugar free
is on my deck, and it's just kind of a scary
thing because you have to
use like malitol, which is uh, you know, I
don't even like the 'tol' at the end, you
know, so I kind of shy away
from it, but these products, like for example,
this is white chocolate mousse with berries
in it and it's gluten
free, so it just depends.
It's not low in fat, it's high in flavor.
[audience laughs]
You know?
Um, so again, it's just choosing which route.
I think that being said, I think desserts
is about like
enjoying and over the top and it's not to
be done everyday, you know?
So when you go for it, you kind a want to
go
for it and you want to really get something
fabulous at the end of it.
So.
Okay, I've got hot cream and milk--
>>female #2: It just has to be hot?
>>Karen: Well, almost to a boil, sometimes
I don't like to bring it to a boil, because
it creates a skin.
Okay.
[sound of liquid pouring]
Okay, this is not for the faint, this pot.
So you just mix it up, stir it all together.
>>Unknown speaker: Is it tough to make?
>>Karen: Sorry?
>>Unknown speaker: Is it tougher than it looks?
>>Karen: Nope.
You don't need, you know, you don't need a
mixer for this, this is like this is..."friends
are coming
over, oh my gosh, what am I going to make?"
[tapping sounds]
And then I need to strain it.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Well, okay, it's a double bowl, we'll deal
with it.
[audience laughs]
Deal with it.
So I'm just gonna strain it through here,
and what that does it it collects all the
potential egg yolk
that didn't, that coagulated that wouldn't
be nice and creamy smooth.
Because let's say you do want this for crème
brulee, you don't want to make bread pudding,
you definitely want everything to be strained
out of here, and it's
nice to have like at the end, you've got the
grains from that vanilla, all the seeds, and
it's good to have all that
in there and people see that you're using
real vanilla beans.
So, I think this will be easy to see.
So we're
going to put half of it into the bottom, and
then half of the croissants, and then I take,
this is two cups of
chocolate, so it's a lot of chocolate, so
even if your croissants aren't flavorful,
they will be.
[audience laughs]
And then I go ahead and I take the rest of
the croissants and I put it on, so it's like
you're building a sandwich.
>>female #3: Can I ask why you have the tin
foil on there?
>>Karen: Because otherwise, my crème brulee
is going to seep out.
So while we were testing this for the book,
we...it
seeped out a few times, and I'm like, hmm,
this isn't going to be good.
>>female #3: From where?
>>Karen: From the bottom, because it has a
push out bottom.
>> female #3: Oh right.
I forgot.
>>Karen: And then, I'm gonna put this in here,
and then you just go ahead and fill up.
So it seems like, oh my gosh
that's a lot of liquid but that's why it's
so wonderfully custardy and then the chocolate's
melted and, it's, we
make this everyday at the store, and everyday
I walk by it and I go, hmm, is anybody looking,
and I like
grab-- because the best part is like this
real crusty.
And then that's it.
You just put it in the oven.
You bake it
off.
You can cool it, and then it will pop right
out and turn into this, and then you can slice
it, and sauce it, and
serve it.
So if I were having you over for dinner, and
I was going to plate the bread pudding, what
we do at the
store and what I like to do is to take some
vanilla anglaise, which is in the book, and
the chocolate sauce, it's in
the book as well, and I just, I'm pretty simple,
I like to just sort of swirl them and marble
the plate, and then
take a scoop of the bread pudding that's nice
and warm and you can also microwave this if
you want, it really depends
what size you want, you get a little bit larger
at Extraordinary Desserts, and then I tend
to go in the yard and grab
whatever's growing, edible or not, and then
I put that on the side of the plate, and then
if you want, I mean, it
depends how fussy you want to get... if you
want to sprinkle the powdered sugar on the
side of the plate.
This is a
tea strainer, a fork, the sugar and you can
do it on anything you like.
And then, basically, you have a finished
product that you can serve, and then the same
thing goes likewise for if you're building
the mousse in the cup, it's
from the Yvoire, it's a white chocolate mousse
that's in a cake in the book.
You can build your white chocolate
mousse, put your fresh berries in the center,
and then some more white chocolate mousse
and then I finished it off
with some raspberry gelee, which could be
the raspberry sauce in the book with a little
gelatin in it.
And then if
you want to put strawberries on it, and raspberries,
or if you just want, you could take, a rose,
and my staff gets
crazy, they love the flowers, so we just do
whatever however, there's no absolute.
It's just pick colors you like and
kind of go for it.
And then I use that same gel that I used on
the top, and I just paint the strawberry so
it looks
like it's more luscious, and then you can
put that on there, and if you're really going
for it, and it's Valentine's
Day, and so you break out the edible twenty
three and three quarter gold leaf,
[audience laughs]
and then you end up with a cup like that.
So it's pretty easy, you can use the gold
on your plate, "Good morning
honey, here's your croissant and your jam"
and put the gold on the croissant.
[audience laughs]
I mean you know, so the book is meant to give
you lots of artistic freedom, and just give
you color options and ways
to think about presenting things that make
people really want to eat it.
So, what else can I answer before we're
going to eat?
[audience laughs]
>>female #4: Hi, thank you for coming today.
I have two questions.
One is that I see you have
graduated from Le Cordon Bleu and you travel
back to Paris frequently, where would you
recommend for a great
croissant or desserts in Paris?
>>Karen: Let's see.
The one that I was at that was my favorite
this last time , I went and I bought four
pieces
of cake and I ate all four of them.
[audience laughs]
In the same few hours.
It's called, Le Reve de Patisserie.
And you can always email me, but that was
like my
very favorite and then of course I went to
a few more and bought a few pieces and ate
those you know because I'm
dissecting, but that one was really wonderful.
>>female #4: Awesome.
I'll be there really soon so--
>>Karen: Great.
>>female #4: The second question is, do you
use ultra pasteurized milk and cream and if
you do, do you
find a difference in the taste, in your desserts?
>>Karen: Well, I'm not sure if it's ultra
pasteurized.
It's organic milk that we use.
We use all organic milk, and
for the heavy whipping cream, it is ultra
pasteurized.
I don't know that it has a better flavor,
I know that the
cream that we use has a higher fat content,
so that means it might have more flavor.
I do like to use organic
products whenever I can.
It was absolutely not affordable to have the
cream organic, we did the math on it, and
it
became thirty five hundred dollars extra a
month to make that switch.
And so, if I had to pass that on to my clients,
I'd have to probably be shutting my doors.
So you know, you just do what you can with
organics, but flavor wise, I
think we're pretty happy with the product
that we use, and it is ultra pasteurized.
>>female #4: Thank you.
>>Unknown speaker2: I have another question.
How do you roll the chocolate like that?
>>Karen: Well this we take a tray like, this
kind of a tray and we stick it in the oven
just to heat it just a
little bit till it's just kind of warm to
touch, and then we have our liquid chocolate
and then we sort of put it
over the top here and once it just starts
to cool, we can put it in the refrigerator,
we pull it out and we wait for
it to get a little bit like tacky, and then
you use like a paint scraper.
And, I think that's in the book.
It is in
the book.
Yeah, I'm like, I can't remember, what.
Anybody else?
All right.
So I think I am having a helper come and help
me plate, right?
So, what I'll do too is I can start cutting
some
of the cakes, 'cause I think we can do that
before--
>>female #4: Can we tell us what everything
is?
>>Karen: Oh that's a good point.
[claps hands together] So the cake over here
on the far right is a Linzer, and it's
in the book and it's actually is in the holiday
section.
The book is split between seasons,every quarter,
summer,
winter, that sort of thing.
This is in winter.
It's white chocolate buttercream with hazelnut
almond cakes with
fresh raspberries and then a homemade raspberry
jam.
So it has sort of an Austrian play on it with
all the nuts in
it.
It's a wonderful wedding cake because as it
sits out at room temperature, the nuts and
the white chocolate sort
of warm up, so it's a great cake to drive
from San Diego to L.A.
It has no problem making that trip.
[audience laughs]
And then next to it are some of these white
chocolate mousses, with the raspberries on
it.
And then we have the bread
pudding, and this is probably the most popular
cake at the store, it's called the Viking,
and it has a chocolate crème
brulee in the bottom of it, and then a milk
chocolate whipped cream, and chocolate pralines
in it, and chocolate
cake.
It's called the Viking because it's pretty
intense, it's hearty, and again this is another
one that's really
easy to take from San Diego to L.A. and not
have any problem.
I travel everywhere around the world with
a cake, I
mean, that's just what, if I'm going somewhere,
people , that's just sort of my calling card.
So I tend to make
things that can make long drives, and the
ones that are the whipped creams and the fruits
and the berries, you can
still drive that from San Diego up to this
area because it's only out for two hours,
as long as it's not Santa Anna
and a hundred degrees out and you're stuck
in traffic for four hours.
So even though they're cakes, they're not
that
fragile.
You know?
You shouldn't be scared of them, in terms
of--
>>female #5: What is that in?
>>Karen: What is what in?
>>female #5: The cake when you are traveling.
>>Karen: Oh, in a box.
>>Unknown speaker: Just in a box?
>>Karen: Each of these cakes is on a cardboard
bottom, and then it is usually on a doily,
cardboard round and then it
just goes in a cardboard box.
So it's pretty easy.
I once went to Sydney for New Year's, and
the plane stopped in
Honolulu, I got out, checked into a hotel
for half a day, put the cake into the refrigerator,
went for a run, came
back, got the cake, boarded the plane for
Sydney and showed up for the New Year's party,
and it was the Linzer, and it
was perfect.
[audience laughs]
I got the flowers in Honolulu, I remember
that.
So you can.
Yeah, they travel.
>>female #5: You have to do it as carry on?
>>Karen: They don't ship, but they do travel,
yeah.
So unless there's any other questions, I'll
start cutting and--
>>Unknown male speaker 2:Just one question,
I am curious , you said you went to school
and how did you decide cakes
was the thing you wanted to do?
>>Karen: Well, I think 'cause when I was in
college I was so entrenched in science, that
this other side started
to happen, and I think from being-- my mom
was a great entertainer, so I think that early
on in life, and my
grandmothers were as well, and I've always
been a vegetarian so learning to be a chef
with meat stocks and things
like that did not interest me.
And this just seemed like a painter's palette.
You know, all the color and after
having lived in Honolulu and then I lived
in Mexico, and as well in Paris.
I mean those are really very colorful,
bountiful places, smells and you know, so.
>>Unknown male speaker 2: Now do you find
that a lot of inspiration for your designs
that you make from places you
visit or where do you find a lot of inspiration?
>>Karen: It's not good for me to be landlocked,
you know I do have to get out quite a bit.
I can find inspiration
pretty much anywhere I go, even if it's just
a Sunday at home with some magazines, but
I really find the most
inspiration in Asia.
In Asian countries, I mean I love Bali, just
the use of the different freshly grown clove
and
you know the coffee beans there, and the flowers
and the essences and teas, that's a great
place, but really anywhere
where I get away from my regular day to day
job and people being able to call me with
the random break downs of a
restaurant.
Because I have a hundred ten employees, and
I'm a sole proprietor so it's kind of a heavy
burden on the
back some days, so if I can just get away,
even just-- it took me four planes to get
back to San Diego from Paris this
last trip, because it was just a real mess,
and I was fine, because I'm like reading my
books, some new recipes, I
brought all these French books back and I'm
like five hours in Madrid, not a problem,
you know, oh and overnight
in in New York, okay, so just being by myself
and quiet, is inspirational.
So.
>>Unknown male speaker 3: So the lemon ricotta
cake is by far my favorite, I like all the
citrus flavors in it.
Where did you start or what were your interests
when you started and how have they progressed
over time?
>>Karen: Well, in terms of flavors?
>>Unknown male speaker 3: Yeah.
>>Karen: The lemon ricotta is one of the older,
there's a family of ricottas, there's the
lemon ricotta, the
passion fruit ricotta, and the blood orange
ricotta, and most of my cakes come from family
members or friends having
a birthday and I don't feel like bringing
the same stock cake, so I kinda have to come
up with something.
So a lot of
the same cakes are used, but a lot of other
different flavor conceptions are put together
with them.
I think when I
started, I probably was a little more straightforward
with my flavors because I was living in Mexico,
and it was
back before they were able to import a lot
of things, so I got lemon, and I was able
to get hazelnuts, so my Linzer
was a little bit different, but the Linzer's
been around for about twenty-two years, the
lemon ricotta as well,
because it was easy to do there.
I think now I'm a little more, I get a little
more out there, but I still think of
my general audience, and I mean , San Diego's
very different than Los Angeles, I mean, I
always call us a big
village, so I don't want to get too esoteric
because that can scare people away.
So, even Matcha tea mousse has been
an interesting concept and yuzu and I'm trying
to think, we don't do well with chestnuts,
making things with
chestnuts, and pear's not a big thing, so
I have to be careful.
And if something doesn't sell, we don't make
it
again.
We eat it, then we're over it.
>>female #6: So what about icings?
When you're trying to decorate with icings,
do you use--
[unintelligible]
>>Karen: We don't work with that at all.
>>female #6: So what is your idea of what
is a good icing to decorate with versus [unintelligible]?
>>Karen: Well, for icings we only either use,
and they're in the book, buttercream, and
it's a French recipe actually
from Cordon Bleu, I have never done anything
different from that.
I've used that since 1985.
Otherwise, we use
ganache, which is chocolate and cream, and
then, we don't really use a lot of icings,
we use icing on our
cupcake.
Icings are American baking and I'm just kind
of getting used to that a little bit, you
know because homemade
desserts are coming back in, so I'm dabbling
with it a little, but it's not something that
I'm trained with
specifically.
Icing in France is usually powdered sugar,
egg white and a little lemon juice and you
use that for
making fancy cakes that are fondant, so I
don't use that a lot.
And in American baking, we see it on a lot
of
cupcakes, we see it on a lot of our banana
cakes, carrot cakes, old fashioned kind of
things, and I think it's very
safe to say that we're very different, .old
fashioned's not our genre.
>>Unknown male speaker 4: Are you ever going
to open a store in L.A.
>>Karen: I don't think so.
[laughs] That's why I was encouraging you,
telling you how easy it is to take the Linzer
too and from, and the Viking and yeah.
Okay?
All right.
>>female #6: Can we take pictures before you
serve:
>>Karen: OH yeah, yeah.
Definitely take pictures.
[Audience applauds loudly]
Thank you!!